hi i'm chris wilson from grinding gear
games
thanks so much for joining us here today
and today is a day about path of exile
you're going to find out a lot of
awesome stuff we've been working on
before we get started though i wanted to
mention that there are twitch drops that
you can win
below the live stream there are some
instructions for signing up and linking
your twitch account with your path of
excel account and if you do that you'll
be eligible to receive the drops
so today's live stream has got four
sections they say you should start your
show with a bang so we're going to start
right off with path of excel 2.
after that we're going to show you path
of exile ultimatum this is an expansion
for regular path of exile that's coming
out literally next week
after that we're going to be joined by
ziggy d who's going to host a q a where
he asks me a whole bunch of questions
from twitch chat
so if you have any questions about the
various reveals make sure to keep them
for the q a
then there's going to be a live episode
of the bay class podcast where take cat
and his crew of path of exile veterans
are going to discuss all of the things
we've announced today
they'll be joined by rory rackham who's
the grinding games developer who is in
charge of the development of the
ultimatum league
all right let's get started you're
probably wondering why has it been so
long since we last showed you any path
of xl2 footage
and honestly this is because the project
is so important to us that we are
definitely taking our time to make sure
that we make the best possible action
rpg
let's watch a new trailer
among ancient ruins evil grows once more
the feed of corruption advances
spreading dread and despair
we must give chase
[Music]
we must hunt down and put an end to this
madness if rake lust
is to survive
[Music]
[Music]
that trailer really shows what we've
achieved with path of xl2 i am
so proud of the efforts of the entire
team and putting that together
at exocon we announced the path of xl2
is a true sequel to path of exile
so that means a new seven-act campaign
it means a whole new skill gym system
new items new monsters character classes
all the ascendancy classes are
completely new it's got cutting edge
next generation graphics as you just saw
basically it's everything you would
expect from a sequel to path of exile
but we're not just throwing away our
legacy we're embracing it
both campaigns will be fully playable
from within the same game plan you'll be
able to play through the original path
of xl's storyline or the new path of xl2
campaign
on the way to the shared end game all of
your old characters will still be
playable and of course any
microtransaction purchases you've made
in path of exile will carry on to the
sequel
at exorcon we introduce the dark forests
of the island of ogam where you start
your journey
today we're proud to showcase path of
exile to second act which takes place in
the vasteri desert
welcome to path of exile to second act
as you saw in the trailer act ii is
centered around a caravan of mariketh
called the ardura who live in the
vasteri desert
you're chasing another caravan from an
opposing tribe called the faraday
there's a set of large ancient gates
blocking the progress of the caravan
through a desert pass
so you're being sent through the
traitor's passage to unlock them we
shall wait here jingak but the military
carts have departed for the gates
make haste
path of xl2 is a lot more than just new
acts we want combat to feel both brutal
and responsive even at low levels
we're ensuring that each weapon type has
unique and different mechanics
each weapon class feels different to
play and today we're going to start by
demonstrating the new spear weapon class
spears are a weapon class favoring
mobility with both melee and ranged
attack options
to that end each spear will grant you at
least one mobility skill
in this case the spear comes with both
an engage and disengage skill
when you engage it increases your melee
damage for a short time and that really
encourages you to be mobile during
combat
one of the skills we're using here is
called whirling slash
when you use whirling slash it creates a
sandstorm that grows in size each time
you use the skill
when you leave the sandstorm it explodes
dealing damage to nearby monsters
a great way to do that is to use the
disengage skill which makes you fly
backwards and throw projectiles
in poe 2 each area's mini boss is a much
more substantial fight with interesting
mechanics
you'll be able to find at least one mini
boss in each area of the game
one thing i love about this boss in
particular is that it destroys the
ceiling when it slams the ground letting
in more light
clever players will notice that if
they're standing in the light then
they're not going to have any rocks
falling on their head
the rapid assault skill that we're using
against this boss does three rapid stabs
followed by a fourth step that deals
more damage and can stun if you're
willing to commit to a long attack time
while developing the skills for path of
xl2 we were really thinking a lot about
designing skills that could be cancelled
early to dodge
or you can commit to the full attack for
maximum damage
[Music]
hey
one of the skills we're using here is
called spearfield which creates an area
of spears coming out of the ground that
impale monsters who walk into them
causing them to bleed as the monsters
move towards you they take damage
so using your mobility skills as a way
to move away from them is a great
strategy here
in path of xl2 we've invested a lot in
our animation system
i'm sure you're noticing the animations
are looking a lot better than they did
in poe 1
but there's also a lot of subtle detail
like characters having different run
animations depending on how fast they're
moving
when we use a quick silver flask here
you can see the character changes to a
sprinting animation
[Music]
now
[ __ ]
now that we've arrived at the ancient
gates we're going to show you another of
the new weapon classes and path of xl2
crossbows crossbows are special and they
ground attack skills implicitly this
particular crossbow grants powershot
which is a high damage single target
attack
in order to modify what powershot does
you're going to need to equip bolt skill
gems which change the type of bolts that
are loaded into the crossbow
here we've got three different bolt
skills that the character can switch
between depending on the situation
incendiary bolts
permafrost bolts can be used to disrupt
packs of enemies to prevent them from
closing in on your position
you can then follow up with
armor-piercing bolts to do plenty of
damage
in this area we're helping asala leader
of the ardura to open the ancient gates
and let the caravan through
[Music]
because the bolt types are the skill
gems support gems that are added to them
will modify whatever the skill is that
you're using
here we're going to add multiple
projectiles to our incendiary bolts
[Music]
i'm
we're doing a lot more interesting
things with monster packs here you can
see some of the monsters patrolling
around
[Music]
[Music]
incendiary balls
armor piercing bolts
i'm a piercing
[Music]
i'm a piercing
[Music]
now we're coming to another example of a
path of exile to miniboss limb the
impaler
a siege crossbow this crossbow grants
the siege cascade skill
the skill is also modified depending on
what type of bolts you're using
[Music]
century books
give these demons
we tried to add a lot more little
details to combat in path of xl2
you might notice that the monsters who
die while burning have charred corpses
we really want to make sure that there's
a feeling that as you leave the
battlefield there's clear evidence of
what combat took place then
[Music]
permafrost
falls
incendiary bolts
armor-piercing bolts
incendiary bolts
incendiary box
mechanism
[Music]
incendiary
this is the perennial king the leader of
the faraday his goal here is to prevent
you from catching the caravan at any
cost
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
we will finish this
he must not escape
quickly he conjures the very sands
against
us
this madness has gone on long enough
the king is not the man i once knew and
said swallow me if i do any more to
enable him
you plan to continue your pursuit yes
you will not catch him
not without me we cannot follow through
the raging sands
let us return to the caravan and
question this defector
this is the ardura caravan your town in
acts 2.
i care not where you came from know what
cast you might have been there
all that matters is that you have shown
yourself capable in battle
jinga remain a friend to the adora
and you shall have nothing but respect
from us
from what your shade has told us the
situation is dire
this balbalic will live or die based on
her usefulness
in pursuit of the seed of corruption ask
her what questions you will
then we adora will decide her fate
you need not trust me you'll see the
truth of my information
soon enough i ask nothing of you
only that you do what you know is right
one of the things we really wanted to do
in acts 2 was to use the mobility of the
caravan to allow the player to choose
how they explore the act
here you're given four options on how to
proceed
there is a tribe of lost man that
inhabits the mastodon bedlands
they worship the bones of those long ago
beasts
and that faith has given rise to
powerful tasks
that can somehow call on storms and
strike
enemies with lightning the king wishes
to steal
these objects of worship and use their
lightning
in war do what you must
though events demand you tread upon a
valley of the dead
do not do so flagrantly keep your
presence
light cleanse what corruption you can
and we shall skirmish with the faradam
to protect your flank
once you've picked your destination the
caravan will travel to that area and
come to a stop so that you can disembark
and go on your
quest
because we just got the storm swear
skill as a quest reward now would be a
great time to switch back to spears and
use some ranged abilities
[Music]
storm spear fires a lightning projectile
which splits on contact
the other skill we're using here is
called blazing lance blazing lance
creates a trail of fire from the ground
dealing damage over time
however if you're willing to stand in
place for long enough you can throw a
second spear that will fan the flames
for much more damage
[Music]
[Music]
we've just found a unique spear it's
called devata's wind
this spear has an extra modifier that
synergizes really well with storm spear
when you disengage you get two
additional projectiles on your
projectile skills
[Music]
so wow
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
well
[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
if you have any questions about what you
just saw we'll be doing a q a later on
while path of exile 2 definitely won't
be released this year
we do have a path of xl expansion you
can play one week from now
i'd like to introduce path of exile
ultimatum
you only live once exile
make your choice
[Music]
a simple ultimatum leave with your life
and a media reward or risk it all
for a chance at ungodly riches
for each trial you accept the challenge
grows
but fail and leave with nothing
reap the reward you deserve
[Music]
ultimate reward requires ultimate risk
face the ultimatum
when some people think of the vowel
civilization they think of
blood sacrifices or queen at zeri or
lost temples in the jungle
but i think of risking your items from
valors through double corruption the
whole vowel or no balls meme
we had to make sure that this expansion
was about the concept
of risking your items to get great
reward
in each area of the ultimatum league
you'll meet the trial master
an emissary of a vile entity only known
as chaos
on behalf of chaos the trial master
enacts trials where exiles must risk an
escalating set of valuable rewards
as they attempt to overcome
progressively more difficult encounters
in each trial you'll be presented with a
reward an objective and a selection of
difficulty modifiers that make the trial
harder
once you've chosen one of the modifiers
you must then complete that objective
under the constraints of that modifier
in order to win the promised reward
[Music]
if you succeed in the challenge the
trial master will present you with an
ultimatum
either walk away with what you have
earned so far or risk it all to try to
win additional rewards
he'll offer you another item if you can
select an additional difficulty modifier
and complete the challenge with both
modifiers present
if you fail though you'll lose both
rewards and walk away with nothing
if you succeed you'll be offered an
additional reward in exchange for adding
yet another difficulty modifier that
stacks on top of the current ones
this cycle continues until the rewards
become increasingly valuable and the
encounter extremely difficult
you'll have to pick a point to end your
run and claim your spoils before you
make the encounter too hard and lose
everything
at its longest an ultimatum and endgame
maps can sometimes have up to 10 fast
trials in a row
with a special surprise in the last one
in maps you'll occasionally find items
called inscribed ultimatums
these items can be placed in the map
device to transport you to the trial
master's domain
each inscribed ultimatum specifies an
offering that you must bring with you
a reward you can earn and an assortment
of ultimatum difficulty modifiers
if you're able to complete the trial the
trial master will reward you with a
specified reward
which is usually worth around twice the
value of the item you must bring
for example you may be asked to risk an
exalted orb to win a stack of two
or potentially risk a stack of five to
win a stack of ten
naturally inscribed ultimatums can be
traded with other players
so if you don't feel capable of
completing a difficult challenge you may
be able to trade it away for a portion
of the difference in price between the
reward and the item that must be risked
likewise if you have a powerful
character you may be able to selectively
trade for profitable ultimatums to run
there are also new unique items that can
only be obtained from ultimatum
one such unique is the glimpse of chaos
vowel mask which provides powerful
benefits to your maximum life
mana and energy shield at the cost of
having severely reduced elemental
resistances and no chaos resistance
the item can be corrupted multiple times
and has unique corruption outcomes
such as removing a random modifier or
transforming it into a different random
corrupted unique helmet entirely that
retains its corruption implicit mod
another new value unique item in
ultimatum is mahuzutl's machination
which grants you six keystone passives
at once
combining all of these keystones results
in some very unusual outcomes
and the item features an entirely new
unique keystone as well
we have worked hard to make sure that
ultimatum doesn't punish you for being
in a party with other players
party members compete in trials together
but have separate rewards available to
them that will need to be locked in to
begin the trial
each player votes on which difficulty
modifiers to select
if there's a draw in votes the modifier
will be chosen at random
if one player wants to take their reward
and opt out to the next difficult trial
they're able to do so without stopping
the other party members from continuing
rewards are dropped allocated to the
players who earned them
so that's path of exile ultimatum i can
tell you on release day a lot of our
developers are looking forward to
watching twitch so we can see players
risking far too much in order to try to
get good rewards
speaking of rewards there's a lot to
talk about here
we had a look at path of exile's past
reward systems
and we honestly feel many of them are
out of date many of them kind of lack
identity and to top it all off like the
core drop pool of just items that drop
when you kill regular monsters just
wasn't really compelling enough
like you know that feeling where any
monster could drop a mirror we want that
for a whole slew of different items and
so we've made a lot of changes to path
of exile's reward systems there's a
bunch of ones to the core drop pool to
keep it really interesting
there's wants to basically every piece
of league and expansion specific content
and we're going to go through all of
those for quite a while now and i should
mention that every change we're about to
discuss
not only affects the ultimatum league
but also standard league too
we started by reviewing which items can
drop from monsters and chests in the
core game
to make sure the core drop pool remains
compelling we've made various changes
you can now find two additional currency
items as core drops orbs of binding from
the harbinger league
and the new veiled chaos orb which we'll
reveal in more detail soon
we've also added five new atlas based
types like this energy shield recharge
amulet
these drop in specific regions of the
atlas of worlds and have some powerful
new implicit mods
another topic related to the core drop
pool is that of boss runs
veteran community members will remember
when people used to do vile oversoul or
dominus runs over and over
because they were a profitable use of
time final axe bosses now drop more and
better items giving you a much more
satisfying close to a difficult act and
a more item-focused approach to getting
ready for maps if you prefer
we have also added a bunch of very
powerful and valuable league specific
uniques into the core drop pool
this means that they can drop from any
sufficiently high level monster without
you having to engage with specialized
content
examples of these are badge of the
brotherhood a salem pledge of hands
maloney's mechanism brutus's lead
sprinkler
and headhunter the goal of all these
changes is to make sure that every
monster you kill and path of exile has a
chance to drop something
incredibly valuable regardless of what
content you're playing
on top of all of that we have added a
handful of new vendor recipes
which let you make some pretty cool
stuff we really miss the days when
players were scrambling to try to find
unknown recipes and so we're looking
forward to seeing how long it takes for
you to discover how these ones work
we have also introduced a new type of
reliquary key into the core drop pool
for this expansion
if you're very lucky you can find a
vowel reliquary key from any monster or
chest and path of excel
when consumed in the map device it gives
you access to a vault with a chest that
drops a special foil version of a vowel
theme's unique item
each unique has an equal chance of
dropping due to the value and power
level of the items contained within
this is the rarest relocate ever added
to part of excel
the rest of our reward changes relate to
items that you can earn by playing past
content like prior leagues and
expansions
we have two goals here the first is to
add and improve items so that all past
content is a compelling set of rewards
the second goal is to make it so the
best way to get any reward is to play
the content that is primarily associated
with that type of reward
path of exile's first expansion
sacrifice of the val introduced a new
ultimate boss
at zerry queen of the valve this fight
holds up pretty well these days
considering that it is seven years old
but its rewards really needed a refresh
the sacrificial guard base type that
drops from at zeri has been
significantly improved with the addition
of an implicit mod that grants plus one
to the level of all valve gems you have
equipped
we have also added two new unique items
to at zerry's drop pool and two more to
overhead series
one of which is the at series rule
judgment stuff which prevents you from
being stunned or having your damage
reflected
it grants a skill that alternates
between flames of judgment and storm of
judgment when used
as if you absorb the powers of etzeri
herself
skipping forward to 2016's release of
ascendancy
we have made some changes to how you
receive your labyrinth enchantments
previously when you completed the
labyrinth and went to enchant an item
you couldn't see what random result
you'd get now the result for each type
of enchantment is shown to you in
advance
so you can make the right choice in the
eternal labyrinth you're now offered
three different helmet enchantments to
pick between in addition to the boots
and gloves
this will make it a lot easier to find
enchantments relevant to the skills
you're using and to apply them to
appropriate items
in 3.14 we're going to stop giving out
unique jewels for each day's fastest
labyrinth runs
and we have added these jewels as very
rare drops that you might find in the
labyrinth's final reward chests
another highly requested labyrinth
related improvement is that you can now
consume an offering to the goddess and
the map device to open portals directly
to a random trial
this greatly accelerates the speed at
which you can find your final trials
we have also added two new labyrinth
specific unique items including
the scales of justice unique shield
which rewards building your character
with a careful balance of life and mana
if used correctly you'll be granted
protection from shock and ignite as well
as additional fire damage
cadero parandis now has a much larger
selection of unique item rewards
we have also rebalanced all sources of
paradise coins so that paradise content
is still the best place to get them from
a craft introduced in harvest kinda
destroyed the parandis coin economy so
we're absolutely fixing that at the same
time
essences have been numerically
rebalanced and are in general stronger
than they were before
screaming essences can now be used to
reroll rare items in addition to their
capability to upgrade items too rare
the four corrupted essences have had
some of their less useful outcomes
improved or replaced
now the only way to get the powerful
upgrade only top tier essences is
through remnants of corruption
which come from essence content
blessings the currency used to upgrade
breach uniques
can now be used to upgrade breach tones
between tears also
[Music]
our best jewels have been rebalanced and
are on average more powerful than they
were before
we have also buffed to best chess to
make sure that they are the best place
to get abyss jaws
we have also introduced abyss scarabs
and have added four new abyss specific
unique jewels
such as techrod's gaze a murderous eye
jewel that increases your main hand
critical strike charms and your offhand
critical strike multiplier
based on how many murderous side jewels
you have equipped
another example is the ulaman's gaze
searching ai jaw which counts how many
searching idols you have equipped and
grants your projectiles a chance to be
able to chain
when colliding with terrain proportional
to this number these unique jaws have a
chance to drop from any of the unique
encounters at the end of the abyssal
depths
and these encounters are now by far the
most reliable way to obtain a stygeon
vice build
we have added a handful of new beast
crafts such as add a mod to a map
or add a mod to an influenced item which
consume existing beasts
there are some other aspects of beast
crafting that we've been keeping our eye
on for a while and we're taking this
opportunity to rework them
so that high level gameplay is less
reliant on obtaining certain beast
crafts
now when you use the splitting
beastcraft recipe on an item
both copies are marked as split which
prevents them from being split again
you cannot imprint split items
one of my favorite reward changes in
this expansion is that incursion's
temple of atsuato can now be itemized
once you have access to the map device
alva can turn your completed and ready
to run temple into a tradable object
that can be consumed in the map device
this means that players can specialize
in either making temples to trade to
other players
or trading for temples that are ready
for them to run
there have also been a lot of changes to
the temple as you may know specific
rooms in the temple of atsuado can drop
unique incursion items that can be later
upgraded
many of these base unique items have
been improved in this update
previously the temple's boss the
omnitech dropped random rare items with
special incursion mods on them
now it also drops rare items with
incursion mods based around the themes
of the rooms your temple contains
higher tear rooms cause more rare items
specific rooms now add specific monster
packs to the temple which results in
more monster density challenge and
reward
temple mods have been buffed so that if
your temple has more high tier rooms
than is equivalent to a good map
we have performed a modernization pass
on rewards from temple rooms so that
they're competitive with rewards from
newer leagues
the explosive shroom also contains some
basic chests that can be opened with
flash powder kegs if you don't need them
for opening a path elsewhere in the
temple
delve has had a big increase to early
rewards and a reduction to the quantity
of high tier rewards spawning at very
deep depths
the end result of that doll was a lot
more rewarding for almost everyone
but a few extreme players who delved
very deep will not be getting quite so
rich from it
a big problem with rewards and betrayal
is that players deem it not worthwhile
to kill katarina because it resets your
betrayal syndicate board
in this expansion we have massively
increased the incentive for doing this
now if you manage to kill katarina all
syndicate members drop their rewards at
one tier higher than they previously
would
this change required the introduction of
a new fourth tier of reward from each
syndicate member and encourages the use
of a larger variety of syndicate targets
and safe house leaders
we have improved rewards that were not
as interesting or valuable as the best
ones
for cases where we deemed rewards too
powerful we moved them to tier 4 rather
than nerfing them
the tier 4 rewards are approximately
twice as powerful as tier 3 ones were
we have also added a new unique item to
katarina's drop pool as further
incentive for killing her
the cane of color mac drops only from
katarina similar to paradoxica it has
three veiled modifiers that must be
unveiled one at a time via jun
this means that each version of a cane
could be entirely different and because
of the way the veiled modifier system
works
you have the chance to get three mods
that potentially synergize extremely
well
or maybe just a crazy bag of mods that
don't work together furthermore the cane
itself scales up the magnitudes of any
unveiled modifiers on it
we have made some changes to how
unveiling mods works you still get
offered a choice of three mods but these
are now more powerful versions of the
existing ones
the powerful ones are unveiled onto
items and the normal versions are the
ones you unlock that can be crafted onto
items
also progress towards unlocking crafting
available mods is at a slightly faster
rate than before
some very powerful veil modifiers are
now only available at their original
strength on the unveiled version of the
modifier
and the crafted version of the modifier
has been lowered in power
earlier in the presentation i alluded to
the new veiled chaos orb as an item that
has been added to path of exile's core
drop pool
this new currency item rerolls the
target at him with new mods like a
regular cow sword does
but one mod is guaranteed to be a veiled
mod while it can drop from many monster
chests in the game by far the most
effective way of getting it is from
isling and some betrayal safe houses
we have introduced three new types of
incubators for blight metamorph and
delirium and have modernized the rewards
from the other incubators
the item yield from chests and blighted
maps is now affected by a portion of the
map item's quantity
giving you a reason to roll your
blighted maps if you can handle the
additional challenge
annoyments to blighted maps have been
rebalanced and reworked so that each has
its own purpose and with a consistent
increase in reward as the oils get rarer
this is basically entirely buffs because
one big nerf we needed to do was already
done last league
you can now corrupt blighted maps these
can very rarely drop the new tainted oil
which allows you to apply anointments to
corrupted items
we have also introduced blighted scarabs
we have added two new types of catalysts
themed around speed and critical strikes
respectively
these new catalysts are rarer than
previous ones
as discussed in the recent development
manifesto the current 3.13 version of
harvest is too rewarding
so we're rebalancing its crafting and
also increasing how often you'll
encounter portals to the sacred grove
the current version spams you with way
too many crafts so each seed has a
chance to ground a craft now
reducing the overall number of crafts
you can perform per garden
you will encounter the growth 60 more
than you did before
some of the most powerful crafting
options have been removed or changed
the heart of the grove encounter is now
a map fragment that can randomly drop
from tier 4 harvest bosses instead of
rarely replacing the entire grove when
it spawns
with the release of ultimatum ritual
will be added to the core game
with a chance to occur in each map you
play it has also been added to the atlas
passive skill tree system and is
available as a sexton mod
almost every time we release a league we
later roll it into the core game with a
chance to spawn in maps
usually 10 sometimes 5 when ritual is
added to the core game we are
standardizing this rate at 8
which means a small decrease for some
leagues and an increase for harvest
we have rebalanced other things to
compensate like the rate at which high
strokes level up
most atlas passive trees have the same
increase in chance for bonus content
meaning they now offer more than double
the chance of encountering your
preferred content
so i just spent a ton of time describing
lots of buffs to path of exile's
different reward systems and there was
one nerf that i left to last
and this gives us a nerf to a league
that i kind of care about a bit talisman
was one that i kind of led the design on
and players joke that it's my favorite
league
now in the 3 12 3 content update
there was a change to talismans
basically they weren't good enough so
the team decided to add a random
annoyment to them which made them a lot
more powerful and also to juice up the
mods to make them well rolled
and that was overkill like as you've
seen recently talismans have just been
dropping with insane mods and great
annoyance and we felt in this expansion
especially because you can use tainted
oils
in order to redo the anointments on
talismans because now you can modify
corrupted amulets
honestly they don't need the well-rolled
mods anymore and so we've removed that
talismans are still compelling
but they're not quite where they were in
the last league
every path of exile expansion needs new
ways for players to slaughter their
enemies
in path of exile ultimatum this takes
the form of four new skill gems and four
support gems
in line with ultimatum's vowel theme
these gems focus on blood
the idea of spending life rather than
mana to use your skills
alongside the new skill and support gems
we've also made some adjustments to the
low life mechanic
including changing the low life
threshold to 50 this makes it much
easier and safer to stay on low life for
builds where it matters
typically when players create low life
builds they rely on energy shield to
protect themselves against incoming
damage
the new skill petrified blood enables
low life builds to instead use some of
their life pool to absorb hits
while it's active you can't recover life
above 50 through any method other than
flasks
sources of life recovery like life
regeneration and life leech only apply
to the bottom half of your life pool
additionally a portion of incoming hit
damage that affects the lower half of
your life pool is spread out over time
rather than being applied instantly
corrupting fever consumes a chunk of
your life and grants you a buff that
causes all your hits to apply corrupted
blood to your enemies
corrupted blood stacks up with each hit
causing more and more physical damage
over time
when you have consumed a certain amount
of life to cast skills from your life
pool
the buff's duration refreshes
essentially as long as you're consuming
life to use skills you'll be causing
damage over time to stack on enemies
be careful though the exsanguinate skill
shoots tendrils of blood in front of you
at the cost of life rather than mana
in addition to a strong physical damage
hit it also applies a physical damage
over time debuff which you can stack up
to three times
you can also support exsanguinate so
that its tendrils chain from one target
to the next
reef conjures a giant bloody side that
swings across a selected area applying
strong hit damage and physical damage
over time
each use of the skill causes it to gain
a charge that scales its damage up and
increases its life costs up to five
times
these charges drop off over time as well
as after killing enemies
making reap very powerful at stacking up
damage against single targets
we've also added two new support gems
that have split the existing blood magic
support into two separate support gems
the first of these is the arrogant
support which causes supported skills to
reserve life instead of mana
and also provides an increase to the
effect of auras that it supports
just like the original blood magic
support gem the reservation multiplier
diminishes as the gem levels up
the lifetap support gem causes supported
skills to cost life instead of mana
once you've consumed a certain amount of
life to use a skill you gain life tap
which increases your damage for a few
seconds
the cruelty support gem grants a buff
called cruelty which increases the
damage of a time you deal with supported
skills
it also boosts the hit damage from
supported skills and the cruelty buff
gets stronger the harder you hit
this gem is designed as an additional
option for builds that focus on both
hits and damage over time
the bloodthirst support gem is a new
option for low-life attackers
this gem adds a percentage of your life
as physical weapon damage while you're
on low life
letting low-life attack based builds
really scale their damage which wasn't
an option before
alongside a vowel themed expansion and
blood themes gems it felt right to take
the opportunity to improve vowel skills
which are supercharged versions of
regular gems that charge up with the
souls of your slain enemies to deal huge
bursts of damage
one of the main improvements is that you
now get far more souls for vowel skills
from damaging unique enemies so your
vowel skills will recharge faster
against bosses
we've also improved yet series reign
unique jewel alongside increasing the
duration of your vowel skills it also
grants a chance to regain all consumed
souls
vowel skills have also received a
balance pass that you can check out in
the full path of excel automate and
patch notes in a few days
so we've covered most of the key
components that make up path of excel
ultimatum
keep an eye on the news over the next
week as we reveal the finer details of
what's coming
we'll move on to the q a shortly to
answer your burning questions but first
let's have a quick look at the new
supporter packs that are available right
now to celebrate the launch of ultimatum
and help fund ongoing development of
path of exile
the silver crescent and imperial sun
supporter packs come with masses of
points to spend in the store
social frames forum titles and badges a
download of the digital soundtrack
and of course exclusive cosmetic
microtransactions such as armor sets
alternate helmets and weapon skins
the silver crescent series has an
exclusive portal effect and the imperial
sun series has an exclusive aura effect
each series has two packs and the
smaller packs can be upgraded to their
respective large pack anytime while
they're still on sale
these are of course in addition to the
new core packs that were released at the
end of last year
remember to check those out if you
haven't already thank you so much for
your support
purchases of these supporter packs are
the only thing that fund ongoing
development of path of excel
its sql path of xl2 and expansions like
ultimatum
the reveals we showed you today are
already live on youtube for you to link
to your friends in case they missed the
live stream
please do so we're keen to get a big
turnout on the release of ultimatum next
week
and we've got plenty more reveals
planned for the rest of the year there's
a lot more path of xl2 stuff to show off
and we've also got some new progress on
path of exile mobile we're keen to share
with you as well
anyway if you have any questions from
what we've shown you today please get
them ready because i'm about to be
joined by ziggy d as we do a q a based
on your questions from twitch chat
you